[Music]
[Music]
today infinity war having fun with that
pretty much true for The Tonight Show
last night yeah and speaking of that
bunch the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
celebrating their 10th anniversary so in
honor of that we figured we would flash
back and show the crew how they've
changed or really haven't changed over
the last decade I want to take you back
cuz this is 10-year anniversary of Bob
only take you back to ten years ago do
you remember you from 10 years ago oh my
gosh look at look at us exactly the same
no you look like you're 13 years old
yeah I don't know what that is but I am
drunk
I look at that face and I know that I
was drinking at that time and I don't I
don't know who that is
I can't write that's Chris head he looks
exactly the same which is to say he's
still super handsome and charming and we
love him so we have an age but even the
Avengers can't say Doctor Strange from
this blast from the past
that's Benedict Cumberbatch in full drag
for a London fundraiser is that ten
years ago ten years ago I was like a
really angry librarian I don't know yeah
you're right I've got quite aristocratic
cards but no Marvel upper body strength
look at that my cleavage is much better
now my arms a bit scary that I was
playing bit earlier in the West End the
first time I ever did anything on stage
with lights and stuff it was pretty
memorable day so now you know it's the
sprinkle down
you only get better that's right
that's from episode of cold case maybe
how you got great hair what was that
hey man I'll live the life I look
exactly the same good God look at
Chadwick yeah looks the same he looks
young what about you smash oh let me see
I'm a you quick
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]